This sister knew that I was making an appearance, but you
acted like it was a matter of course
Why doesn't your attitude towards me change?  I
don't know what your words
should be believed, or my
attitude won't change, so I do
n't know what to do.  Just like my
blood didn't understand your sister until now, do
you not understand me?
This older sister here is a good guy It's
not a lie that she wants to be liked by Ayanokoji-san
This older sister is different She's
different from him I
'm scared to be found out that I'm acting
People in my class found out a long time ago  At that time, he
went
around calling me a liar, and that made me feel terrible.
No, that guy's name is
Mitsutsuki Yano
[music]
Why
me?